[Music]
i'm wesley lowry a journalist with cbs
news and gq magazine and a little bit
everywhere
here to talk about judas and the black
messiah at the iron revolutionary
scene chuck i wanted to start with you
can you talk to me a little bit about
how that scene comes together how you're
thinking about it
you have this man going up the steps
feeling sort of like a gladiator
entering the ring
hearing the crowd chanting his name
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in that moment felt almost like an arena
you know when he steps into that massive
crowd of folks
it's almost like they left the pants
about the cage
i'm free
[Applause]
i'm free y'all
i need everybody to be after me i am
a revolutionary
[Applause]
in this scene we have fred hampton
giving
this remarkable speech this is what we
call the people be
started in 1966 by here we knew him
bobby seal
it's the beat that manifests in you the
people
and we also see all of the other main
characters
silently reacting and responding they
can't never
how do you convey so much story and
emotion
to a scene in which the vast majority of
your characters
have no lines well i always knew that it
was kind of the junction for every
major character's storyline
and so it's just figuring out the best
way to
photograph that so that the intention
that they
are feeling in the moment shines
[Applause]
when you see daniel going for it like
that
you're like i don't want to cut away
from this right
but i have to because these story beats
are
integral to the entire story that we're
telling and then you see that the beats
and they kill in the beats and you're
like
it's a good problem to have
[Applause]
you know everyone had an emotional
attachment and
a political attachment to this material
and so everyone's like bringing their
best
imagine what we could accomplish
together we can heal this whole city
this is gonna be one of the emotional
high points the emotional high point of
this film
daniel how are you prepping to walk out
on the camera
and do this when i do scenes i think of
who i want to speak to
who i want to feel moved by this is who
it means everything to
and i hold that in my prayer so if you
asked to make a commitment at 8 20 you
said i'm too young to die and you're
dead
already i remember listening to him and
being
moved he was just embodying this
character and
we would just have chills at times just
how compelling it was
it was just hard to be hearing those
words delivered in the way that
daniel delivered them and not feel
something
i remember feeling grateful that it
wasn't my coverage the first time i was
hearing it
because i don't know if that would have
been
accurate for mitchell daniel what do you
think
chairman hampton is thinking as he says
some of these words
he has been imprisoned he's seen
comrades
killed and he's confronting the idea of
his own individual mortality
it's just like clear really clear
where defensive hand for comrade jimmy
obama
jimmy obama got a revolutionary deal he
died protecting the people
and as far as i'm concerned that's the
only way to die
i think if there's ever a moment in the
movie where
he doubts that his mission will succeed
it's while he's
you know incarcerated and he comes out
to see that
his mission has been a success he was
like wow this
confirms what i feel this is bigger than
just me
there's power anywhere there's people
the people have come together
and driving and doing better than ever
and so that's what's going on with
chairman fred hampton
simultaneously william o'neill he's the
entire time
been completely apolitical he's been
existing within the movement with
panthers
say chairman there wasn't no goddamn pig
he was eating out there wasn't it
somebody got to show the pig whose balls
man
he's also been running his side gig with
the fence
when one group presents a conflict to
him he runs to the other side
does anybody else know about me no my
superiors no i have a man on the inside
but that's it
no one knows your identity suddenly they
all collide in the same room
how does that come across in this scene
he's in a vulnerable space and so
he like the rest of the people in that
crowd they hear chairman fred hampton's
words and they're starting to resonate a
little bit
i think mainly for o'neill it manifests
his frustration
with his own internal conflict and not
you know being confused about
these new emotions that he might be
feeling
and you see in that shot you see that
moment of
him for a brief second becoming a true
believer
and then he spots roy mitchell in the
audience looking at him
and in some ways taunting him i'm really
finding mitchell in the crowd
you know it's not fake so when you see
it happening that's really me oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] in here you know so
then it brings me back to the
reality of the mission and the
characters jessie is
a masterful reactor and in that scene
you see his ability his skill of doing
that is phenomenal
you know because he's [ __ ] with
o'neill when he did that eyebrow raise
like you know the look on his face is so
apathetic
i mean just like even in his eyes it's
just like he's like
i don't give a [ __ ] with y'all alone
like the focus is
completely elsewhere which i think is
great
what some of you might be in the
audience right now huh god in your head
yeah see what did you think was going
through roy's head in that moment
i feel like for rory the power that fred
possessed and his ability to move a
group of people like that
america's on fire right now but we're
here to change that
it's about the scariest thing you could
have seen our counter-intelligence
program
must prevent the rise of a black messiah
he seemed to have a fearlessness about
him we performing a rainbow coalition of
oppressed brothers and sisters of every
color
even knowing what the likely
consequences would be
for the truth that he was speaking think
of your family now
agent mitchell our entire way of life
it's at stake if we lose this war
you follow me i do uh sir the fbi was
guilty of what it accuses its enemies of
and i think that's really important to
make that known an informant killed
another panther
sam's is one of our guys and we're just
letting him walk for murder they spied
on millions of people
and use all of their resources to
neutralize folks and to take down a
movement
so anytime he goes into a panther office
we get a warrant for harboring a
fugitive it's beautiful
that's what i love about a certain part
of this depiction when it shows how
ridiculous and futile it looks when
people perceive positions of power to
try to
come down on people that question that
power
[Applause]
dominique can you talk to me about the
conflict
that deborah's feeling in this moment i
feel like she's like
soaking him in with her eyes like is
this the last time i'm seeing
and then she's feeling like how is that
fair you get to go out there
talk about dying of revolutionary death
and how your
your body belonged to the revolution
because you don't have another person
growing inside your body dominique
reasons just a glimmer of a doubt of
is this a good idea is this safe am i
being a good mother
and so you see her questioning and
really fearful about her future
so you regret it what i had my baby
do you when i dedicated my life to the
people i dedicated my life
i think in him realizing it and him kind
of accepting it before the unspoken
truth
means that i have to face it as well and
come to terms with it i believe i'm
gonna die no car ready
i don't believe i'm gonna die sleeping
on no ice
i don't believe i'm gonna die cause i
got a bad heart
i believe i'm gonna die dude i was born
and so in that moment she has to
relinquish her dreams that she had for
him
then say he is a dream bigger than all
of us
i believe i'm gonna die half the people
i'm going to die for the people because
i live for the people
one of the things that i know for a fact
made
that scene work was the location we shot
in
that space when i saw it i was like we
have to get this location
that was a real church with 350 plus
people in the church standing room like
a true old baptist
you know church that i can remember
going to when i was a kid
that color the vibrancy of the church
helps to create that sense of period
that we were looking for
the scene was very alive and the crowd
helped make everything
alive as well and make it you know feel
like we were really in that space and
place the
feeling in that room was something that
i will never forget no no no it was
crazy they were just lifting me up
like in the breaks women just like oh
you're back i got your back i got your
back man i got you back
it's just like it's like it's not it was
just support and love
when we started that scene i ran up to
shaka
and i said is it all right if we have
the crowd just totally react
with with daniel and just go back and
forth
like uh is it okay to let all this just
happen in real time
and i was i was really glad that you you
know marlo you had that
that thought man because right this the
movies are totally
it's not just a different scene without
that decision it's a different movie
without that decision the crowd
feeds him they give him energy
that's why you see daniel just put on
one of the best performances i've ever
seen in that moment
it's not a question of violence or
non-violence it's a question
of resistance to fascism or
non-existence within fascism
why do you think or do you think those
words
resonate in this moment they feel
powerful
now not in a historical context but in a
today context
a lot of the things that he was
advocating for are things that are still
very relevant
you know over half you know over half a
century after
his assassination war is politics with
bloodshed
and politicians without bloodshed he was
someone who was an incredible thinker
teacher who was ahead of his time
in many ways it's all right then the
declaration independence
live liberty happiness i also think his
ability to communicate
with so many different kinds of people
was not seen before
what fred was preaching he says it in a
really beautiful
grabbing way let me make a play how many
years later
we're still talking about these words
you can murder a liberator you can't
murder liberation this is the soundtrack
of what's really happening out there
you can run a revolutionary but you
can't run a revolution
nothing is dressed up it's naked he's
capturing the essence
of what he means and what he believes
[Applause]
i think that that's why he and his
comrades were willing to die
because they were convinced that they
were going to win and that their death
wouldn't be in vain
when you talk about the real people
they've made peace that they're deaf
from the moment that they signed up is
that phrase that a revolutionary's life
ends with prison
exile or death and so we're making a
movie about
icons we're trying to humanize so that
we really bring their sacrifice to the
surface
they can kill fred
but that hampton kill his message his
influence is so
so deep and and pervasive and it's it's
just so strange to me that he doesn't
get the same level of reverence as say
a king or a malcolm x it really is the
truth
for all those things to be happening at
one time and all of them to work
so well was just a magical moment it's
one of my favorite scenes
to have written as easily my favorite
thing i've ever
directed everybody